welcome to get for data data versioning
for reproducible data science with adult
I checked this isn't the longest title
for a talk at the conference but it is I
think in the top three so I did pretty
good there uh let's get right into it
starting with who am I my name is Zach
Musgrave I lead developments on adult
database which is a new kind of SQL
database that has git-like Version
Control semantics so we're going to go
into some detail about how that works
later on in the talk it's made by adult
Hub which is a 20 person database
startup based out of Santa Monica we
also have a Seattle office where I'm
from so I'm very gently today before
that before working at build Hub I was
at Google you might remember me from the
memes that I made before that I was at
Amazon not Microsoft you want to clear
the record there I've never worked in
Microsoft it's about any Microsoft
connection uh
so next question is what is adult what
is this weird database so adult is this
uh this new new way of approaching SQL
databases uh that treats them like a git
repository so all of the version control
operations that you can do on a git
repository you can do to adult database
so that means you can create branches
merge those branches into each other you
can push the database to a remotes
somebody else can clone the database
from that remote so it enables this new
kind of collaboration of the same sort
that we've had for Source control with
Git for you know over a decade now to
SQL databases so we're the first
database in the world to do this we
think it's pretty cool next question
everyone always has is why is it called
adults are you calling me stupid this is
on this is in our FAQ we're not calling
you stupid you're very smart I know
because you came to my talk uh for those
not you know on the joke we named adults
to pay homage to how lens toront is said
to have named git so git is British
English slang for an unpleasant person
or an idiot so we kind of wanted to keep
that joke going forward because git is
our main inspiration so we want wanted a
short word that meant idiots starting
with d for data and we ended up with
adults
so the next question people have is that
sounds cool but why are you doing this
we very frequently write technical blogs
that we post to places like uh you know
LinkedIn and Reddit and Twitter and so
on uh and very frequently we'll get this
comment of you guys must be crazy uh
it's stupid to write your own database
it's 2022 you could read you could use
postgres you could use sqlite and go on
top of them you must be really dumb we
don't think we're dumb we think we have
a good reason for uh for doing this and
we'll get into the technical details of
why that is but the short story is when
you want to build a database that has
Version Control capabilities you do have
to start with first principles and build
it from the ground up to store your data
in a fundamentally different way to make
that possible
if there was any doubt this is us on the
left in this diagram
so before I get talking about any of
that I want to start off with a brief
introduction of the history of data
sharing uh for a couple different
reasons first because I think it's kind
of cool and interesting and it kind of
sets the stage for what's going to come
next but also because when we talk about
reproducibility and Version Control in
data science we're always talking about
this in the context of teams when you're
an individual you can do whatever crazy
stuff you want with your with your data
you can name the files
final.1.csv and no one's going to call
you on it when you work in a team
setting and you actually need to
collaborate with other people when you
want to share your results with other
people that's when the this data sharing
aspect becomes critical and you can't
just kind of make it up as you go along
so let's talk about this starting in
1972 on all the way back to the days of
Fortran so Fortran at the time uh the
Euro we're talking about here kind of
occupied a similar Niche to what python
does today which is to say if you were
doing uh if you were writing code to do
some sort of numerical simulation for
science or engineering or research
chances are you were writing uh Fortran
back then or is it still used today but
but the trend is is towards python as
everyone in this room understands and
the interesting thing about uh about
Fortran in context of this talk is that
they kind of invented or at least
standardized what we now call the CSV
file on the separated value uh so
everyone in this room has dealt with
lots of CSV files and you know all their
foibles a fun fact about CSV is that
there wasn't really a spec when they
invented it it seemed kind of obvious
and self-describing which is one of the
reasons it's caught on and and persists
to this day but it also means that
there's a lot of compatibility problems
uh so it's always kind of a gamble if
you export data from one file or from
one program into CSV and then try to use
it in some other context or with some
other library that you download off
GitHub God help you anything might
happen if you haven't embedded comment
in a field if you have a new line if you
have some binary characters or Sports on
Unicode characters you just don't know
what you're going to get that's kind of
part of the course and people have
learned to to work around these this
problem with with very clever Solutions
uh so that was 1972. here are some other
pieces of technology that were kind of
currents in 1972 which to make you feel
old was 50 years ago so with the
exception of that sweet muscle car which
I think we all can agree is still very
current uh the world's kind of moved on
from most of the technology that we that
we have
consider relevant currents back in 1972
but not CSV CSV is is still around uh
and this isn't to say that that old
technology is useless or should
universally be replaced uh other pieces
of Technology invest in this in the 70s
include sea and SQL both of which are
still very relevant and useful but just
to say that it's a little surprising
when you stop and think about it that's
something that that's that old is still
kind of a going standard for this
particular domain
so of course this did start to change uh
in the 90s America signed on this this
textbook kind of dates from that time
people kind of started getting home home
internet connections around 1995. uh so
this kind of uh underscored the need for
there to be modern data interchange
formats CSV wasn't going to fit anymore
and so this is the era when we got a
couple new formats they're also still
left this today XML in 1998 and Json in
2001.
uh and the reason these became more
popular and and spread pretty pretty far
pretty fast was the the web services
technology Microsoft was pushing this at
the time sun and Oracle a lot of vendors
got into the web service space and
really kind of uh collaborated around
these two formats if you were around in
kind of the mid-2000s you remember how
dominant XML was at the time uh at the
time they were saying that XML is the
only thing that sun and Microsoft have
ever agreed upon therefore it's going to
be with us until the heat death of the
universe but of course we know that's
not what happened in fact Json came to
completely dominate the the text Data
representation of of data to the extent
the words it's rare to even see XML
files anymore um if you encounter an XML
file it's probably to support some
Legacy application that was written in
the mid-2000s people aren't writing new
applications that take X and all anymore
and of course this is for a lot of
reasons Json is more compact uh it's a
much simpler language spec so it's
really easy to write a parser for it and
put that into some other language which
has come along but this would happen uh
and that kind of brings us up today this
is the the state of play in 2022. if
you're sharing data on the internet
you're doing it in one of these two
formats there's Json or CSV and the way
you're sharing them is also often kind
of protive which is to say you're
zipping it up you're making a tarball
and you're putting that thing somewhere
on some hosted uh sharing sites or FTP
drive or something and letting other
people come and download it uh this is
starting to change a little bit so
people are starting to use Version
Control on these on these textual data
representations uh they'll put them into
a git repository and then host that
thing on GitHub the same way they would
with their source code and this is great
except that it doesn't really scale up
very well once you have in the
neighborhood of you know hundreds of
megabytes of data trying to host it in
something like gets uh as Tech as Text
data is just going to make your life
really challenging it wasn't designed to
work with hundreds of megabytes of data
and there's let alone gigabytes and
there's some workarounds with this like
get lfs then host them in S3 and do
other things but when you when you
resort to those things you lose a lot of
benefits of what makes gets a compelling
Version Control solution in the first
place
and of course this is a python talk so
I'd be remiss to not to avoid mentioning
that there are some other formats that
people potentially sometimes use for
sharing data but I think I don't think
that I'm out of bounds to say that these
are kind of marginal and restricted to
the python Community people outside
python aren't sharing pivot files and
and as data frames on on the web one
exception is sqlite sqlite is a little
compact SQL database representation that
you can for small data sets check into
GitHub like anything else it is a binary
file so you don't get any of the gets
branch and merge logic that you that you
would get if it was a it was a text file
but people are doing this and it has
caught on to some extent
okay so that brings us up to speed on on
where we are with with uh data with data
sharing and this is a topic near and
dear to our hearts when we set out to
write dolt this was kind of the first
use case we targeted we decided look the
way people are sharing data online is
broken uh these large text files don't
scale up to be usable and the binary
formats make all the Version Control
tools kind of unusable so what do we do
about this
uh we're going to talk about that in a
little bit but first I want to kind of
overview give an overview of what I mean
when I talk about reproducible data
science and talk about what data Version
Control can add to a data science
workflow so I'm not a data scientist I'm
a software engineer I'm writing a
database I'm not doing data analysis but
I do know some data scientists and I've
talked to them about this so this is an
outside review thirty thousand thirty
thousand foot understanding of what data
science looks like from the outside so
I've divided up a data processing
pipeline into these four stages here
which I'll talk about
uh the first one I'm calling Source uh
this is basically just the phase where
you haven't done any processing on Raw
data so you're getting data uh it could
be training data that you're generating
in-house and doing doing uh feature
labeling on it could be data that you're
sourcing from online you might be paying
someone else to download some data sets
or just sorting it from online in one of
many many different ways or increasingly
it could be the output from some other
pipeline somewhere in your organization
I call out cleaning as a separate phase
because anecdotally this is kind of a
major pain point in data science I know
that a few years ago data scientists
identified this as taking something like
80 of their time just getting the data
from from some some place that they
didn't control and mudging it until it
was something usable that could shoot on
by the rest of their pipeline
um so I'm hoping that that has gotten
better uh since the last time I looked
at these polls but my impression is that
this is still a major pain point so
cleaning is is the step that I'm that
I'm calling uh making the data usable
for the rest of the pipeline without
introducing any sort of semantic changes
right so you're not doing any analysis
you're not doing any real transformation
you're converting it from one format to
another you're fixing obvious errors
that sort of thing just making it so
your pipeline can process it
then we have this analyze phase which is
kind of useless because it's a black box
uh this is where all the actual logic
happens all the magic of machine
learning or data analysis whatever your
your specific domain is trying to
accomplish happens here uh you're
running arbitrary code in python or some
other language uh and this this could be
you know arbitrarily complex you could
have in fact a directed graph of various
sub-processes running whose inputs feed
into one another that's all great I
can't really speak to that because again
I'm not a data scientist but I do know
that at the end of the day you produce
this results that you want to do
something with so in the ml context your
finished result is going to be something
like a machine a large language model
you can then build into a product or
sell access to if you're doing research
of some sort or some kind of analysis
then you get some sort of aggregate
results that you you get when you crunch
those numbers and you want to share that
thing with the world
so now I'm going to make a kind of bold
claim which I don't think is actually
that controversial which is that doing
data science reproducibly requires some
form of Version Control and there's kind
of a weak version of this claim and a
strong version of this claim the weak
version is that in order for your data
science to be reproducible you must be
able to given a particular artifact that
your data processing pipeline has
produced be able to identify via some
system of metadata or tags or something
where it came from that is to say you
have to know exactly what version of
your data input files were used at every
step through the pipeline and you have
to know what version of your code was
running
if you know those two things you can
exactly reproduce uh the same run to
figure out if if it actually works the
way you think it does and do further
experimentation if you don't know those
things you can't actually reproduce your
results I think this should be
relatively uncontroversial I've used
these kind of gits uh git like uh commit
hash numbers here to represent the idea
that these things are snapshots of of
the data that are pointing off somewhere
else it doesn't have to be good uh the
the weak version of this claim all you
need is some system which is capable of
identifying a particular set of of data
sources and code and giving giving that
snapshot a name so you can then refer to
it and build that into your metadata
however there's a stronger version of
this claim which is that all the the
benefits of Version Control that you get
when you're doing software developments
at scale uh also apply to your data data
processing pipeline in ways that I think
a lot of people haven't really
considered simply because the tools that
we have available to us are so bad they
don't do what we want them to so let's
walk through the the pipeline again and
look at how Version Control actually
helps the task at hand how it helps make
our lives as data scientists it's easier
I'm saying using the Royal weeks again
I'm not actually a data scientist
so starting with with the sourcing
change here or the sourcing stage rather
uh it's very common when you're when
you're running the data processing
pipeline to want to always have the most
up-to-date data so for example you're
training a model to be able to pick
stocks correctly so you always want to
have the most up-to-date stock market
information being fed into your model uh
but this is kind of hazardous because
you don't you aren't in control of this
data source you can't vouch for whether
it's accurate how it's changing over
time so it's very common for people on
the outside world to break you by
introducing changes here so they might
add a column to their to their CSV file
they might drop a bunch of data that you
were expecting later on in the pipeline
there's lots of there's almost a you
know unlimited number of ways that this
could happen the point is here how can
you actually even understand if it did
happen because we're dealing with data's
data files that are very large and
there's not really a great way to diff
them efficiently using the data Version
Control tools available for us it makes
even detecting these changes before they
get Target on the pipeline pretty
difficult
this is also very true in the in the
cleaning phase because uh if you're if
your cleanup script has an error again
this is going to
become an error that gets magnified as
it flows Downstream of the pipeline how
do you detect that early if you don't
have good different capabilities uh one
workflow that we that we've seen work
very well for the for people who have
adopted adults is a Version Control tool
for their data is using it to manage the
states of their cleanup so to give an
example if you have one branch of your
uh of your data Version Control
kind of pegged to the latest changes
that are coming in from an outside
Source you label that raw and then you
create a branch off of that which has
all the cleanup that you've done for
every version of the raw data that comes
in it's possible to then merge those two
branches into one another with the
result being that you have most of your
data already cleaned up because most of
the data stays the same between
particular raw imports from time to time
but you get uh
and the data that hasn't been cleaned up
yet kind of sticks out sore thumb and
you can identify that using the diff
capabilities
uh in the analyze phase here there's
almost an unlimited number of things
that can go wrong and it's uh you do
need the these diff capabilities when
you're doing kind of this debugging uh
workflow for code we have something like
gits we can figure out what are the
commits that have changed between
between this version of the code and
this version of the code what could I
what could I have done and introduced
this error that I found but again
there's nothing similar for for the data
you're doing that sort of dip analysis
is really challenging
finally here uh at the end when you get
your results again how are you going to
notice that something went wrong how are
you going to identify those problems
hopefully before you share them with the
rest of the world or build them into a
product where you get bad results if you
do find some some problem in the result
that you're producing are you confident
that you can actually Trace that problem
all the way back Upstream to figure out
what causes what change in the code what
changing the data actually it gave me a
bad result and the claim here is that
Version Control helps you do these
things Version Control on your data in
this exactly the same way the Version
Control on your source code helps you
debug problems uh in source code
uh so just to reiterate here uh there's
this need to kind of understand what has
changed over time in your particular in
your pipeline itself so uh how my source
inputs changed over time uh how have how
has my code changed over time we want to
be able to answer those questions
effectively you also need to understand
how the the pipeline itself is changing
over time uh or sorry how the data is
changing as it flows through the
pipeline so is it easy to understand
what you did exactly between sourcing
the data and cleaning it up is it easy
to understand between any two particular
phases of your pipeline what
Transformations were being applied and
if you can't answer these questions
effectively you're just going to have a
really difficult time tracing backwards
Upstream to find the source of any
problem that you have
so we aren't the first people to notice
that this is an issue uh there's been
kind of a influx of tools into the into
the data versioning space and there's a
lot of them available now
uh we wrote A Blog about this called so
you want data Version Control you search
for data Version Control on Google
you'll see it's on the first page you
can you can click there and read about
these uh there's quite a lot of them
available I think there's actually
probably been a few new ones that have
spun up since we originally wrote this
blog about a year and a half ago and if
you take one thing away from this talk
uh it would be you should really invest
some some time and effort into
understanding at least what the problem
in solution space is for data Version
Control because it is worth at least
considering what it could add to your
data science practice
but of course I'm not here to talk about
any of these particular products I'm
here to talk about adult uh because I
think it's really cool and my company
makes it
uh so relative to these other things
adult has unique capabilities as far as
we're aware that aren't available in any
of their products uh specifically we can
do branches and merges on both the
schema and data kind of at scale so all
these other data data versioning
products have things that they call
branches and they have operations that
they call merge but they don't work the
way that you would expect coming from a
source control background that is to say
if you and I have the same or if you and
I have both made changes to the same
data file and on different branches and
we try to merge those two changes
together that's a merge complex it
doesn't matter if we change totally just
disjoint sets of data the tool doesn't
understand well enough how to merge
those two things together don't this
isn't the case as long as you and I are
editing the same table we can as long as
we touch disjoint sets of rows those two
changes merge together quite cleanly and
we'll get a demo of that happening in
just a minute
uh these other tools a lot of them do
handle large data in the sense that you
can upload as large data files as you
want to they're just most of them
storing them at S3 or some other cloud
storage solutions so it can scale up to
quite large files the problem is when
you when you do that you lose all the
Version Control capabilities that you
might have gotten if they were kind of a
small manageable size and with adult
this is the case we have databases that
are that are a quarter terabytes and
people are creating bigger ones every
day but you can still do efficient diff
and merge operations on it was built
from the ground up to enable that
uh speaking of storing large files adult
is I think the only product that does
some real form of structural sharing
when considering snapshots uh so if you
have a particular set of files and you
change a little bit of data and you want
to make a new snapshot of that ideally
the storage cost that you're paying is
proportional to the size of the thing
you changed you're not doubling or
tripling the size of your of your of
your data storage bill every single time
you make a new snapshot and this this is
exactly what most of these tools do
because they don't understand uh the
structure of the data well enough to be
able to to do an efficient dip operation
therefore do structural sharing
finally the the thing that we think is
is really cool about about this
technology uh is that we instead of
trying to reinvent the wheel the wheel
in terms of our interface we just copied
two relatively uh well understood and
popular products so for the version
control stuff built work just like git
and in fact the command line is
identical to get so if you know how to
use git you already know how to use
adults there's no uh there's no learning
curve you just type one word instead of
the other uh if you want to connect to
those like a SQL Server which is what
the majority of our customers uh how
they how they use it then any tool that
speaks to my SQL dialects can just and
the MySQL wire protocol you can just
connect seamlessly it's basically a
drop-in replacement to mySQL
so in addition adult we also have adult
hub uh these two products have the same
relationship as git and GitHub so don't
Hub is a website where you can host
adult databases and ads features like
creating Forks cloning those things you
can push and pull to it as a remotes you
can open pull requests on data to make
changes to someone else's data set and
request that they merge it into the into
the main branch while issues against
them and so on and so forth
so when I when I say that that we built
this thing from the ground up to make
diffs fast uh this this is kind of a
slide that illustrates what I'm talking
about here so other database products
and other data version control products
do Implement some version of of a diff
operation or emerge operation the
problem is it wasn't built to actually
support that in an efficient manner so
what you see here is the result from
sqlite3 which recently added support for
giving two databases we're looking for a
single row change and a database of a
varying size you can see quite clearly
that sqlite kind of scales linearly with
the size of the of the database whereas
adult scales basically with the size of
the Delta it actually is it's a little
more complicated now there's a log
factor in there somewhere but the point
is that it's it's we built this this
stuff in the ground up in order to make
these operations fast and you can really
see it as the size of the data scales
out as you get into the tens and
hundreds of millions of rows it really
makes a huge difference in being able to
use these operations on a daily basis
the reason this is the case is because
we built this the the data storage in
this novel way using this novel data
structure that we call a trolley tree uh
we didn't invent this but we are we
think the first to apply it to SQL
tables and and productize that into a
version controlled SQL database so a
probably tree is a lot like a b tree
which is how most databases store their
data the difference is every node in a
poly tree has a cryptographic hash
similar to how git identified snapshots
of files we can check in uh what this
means is that when you're comparing two
databases that represents two versions
or two snapshots of the same database to
compare them you just start walking the
the root node in each one and as you
walk down the tree anytime you encounter
a child pointer that has the same
cryptographic hash you know that that
entire subtree is completely identical
and you can just skip over it so this
means that we can we can diff these two
databases kind of proportional to the to
the number of things that are different
rather than proportional to the size of
the entire data set which which makes a
huge difference
okay so now that you understand a little
bit about Dolce and his capabilities
let's go ahead and do a quick demo where
I show these things off
so starting with adult Hub on the right
here you can see I'm looking at the
cities and states example database uh
and this is just a really tiny toy data
set that I that I wrote In order to
write a blog post about I just chose
some cities in the US let's start with
the letters A and B and put them into a
database along with their populations
according to Wikipedia and I've cloned
this thing on my laptop over here so if
I look at my current directory I've
already cloned it I'm in the cities and
states example directory and if I type
adult status I can see the current
branch that I have checked out if I type
the log I can see the commit history for
this database so these commands should
look familiar they're exactly the same
commands as you would use if you were
exploring adult a git repository uh
you're just you're typing the word adult
instead of the word git everything else
works exactly the same
so for this exercise let's figure out
how to add some data to this data sets
and make some changes and then put them
up on build hub so in the directory on
above me I've got this CSV file city.csv
and it's got a bunch of cities starting
with the letter c so I'm going to add
some C cities to this database and
update it
the first thing I want to do is create a
new Branch to work on because that's
kind of a faux pod to work directly on
Main adult and in gets so I'm going to
call this thing Zach new Slash new
cities
uh and again this this command should
look very familiar because it's exactly
the same as the command you would type
and get switched to a new branch
so once I have this new Branch I'm going
to import that table uh so the command
here doesn't have a git equivalent adult
table Imports
cities branch
okay so it tells me that I have
processed 10 rows and if I want to see
what changed I run this build diff
command and I get this output showing me
hey you've added these 10 rows to your
data sets here's what they are great
let's go ahead and commit those things
so I'm going to run the adults
commit command
and say new cities
okay so I have created a new commit
there's my new commit hash and the
message I typed in if I run the log
command I can see it has a new commit
there
okay so now that I've done that let's go
ahead and do some some sort of
collaborative workflow where I'm going
to make some changes on two different
branches and then merge them back
together
so the first thing I want to do is
create those two branches I'll call them
uh
B and then Chuck one of them out
a branch first
run adult status to make sure I'm on the
branch but I think I am so
in order to
edit these
edit the database I'm going to pop into
this interactive SQL shell that ships
with the product I just type build SQL
and now I'm in uh working on the
database if I select star from cities I
can see everything that's in there so
all my changes to a b and c now I'm
going to run an update statement to
update the populations of these cities
so these came from Wikipedia I'm going
to update the population a little bit in
order to reflect how it's growns in the
last census just add two percent to
everything across the board but only
where the where the city starts with a
okay exit out the shell and if I run the
don't diff command
here's the changes I made old row and
new row it looks just very similar to
get output when you're running get diff
uh so I've just updated the populations
of all the cities that start with a
and I'm going to go ahead and Commit
This thing
and say updated
it's probably not the Aspen you think of
probably a different aspect
okay so now that I've done that let's go
ahead and check out my other branch
I'm going to do the exact same thing
run adult SQL and then run that same
update statement but on the B cities
and back on the command line you can see
that my my diff only encompasses those B
cities I'll go ahead and check that in
the same way I did before
uh okay great now let's switch back to
the original Branch we were working on
which is called exact news new cities
right
I spelled my own name wrong
so the uh to merge those in I'm just
going to type the adult merge command
and this works exactly the same as git
merge I just give it a branch name and
it merges that Branch into the one that
I'm on so start with the A1 this is a
fast forward merge because there aren't
any intervening commits between the
commit histories there and then let's do
the B1 it's not a fast forward merge
because there is a you're getting
commits and then I can run the adult log
command to see what's changed so here I
see I created a merge commit and then
here's the commit I made of the E branch
and the one I made on the branch
and I can just I can diff these as well
if I run don't diff on the thing before
head uh this is the the B changes 2b4
head includes the A and B changes and
three before had includes the AMD
changes as well as adding
adding and of course these these uh
these diff commands take exactly the
same kind of arguments that they do on
get
great so now that I've made my changes I
want to share them with the rest of the
world so I'm going to push them back to
my remote which is dot Hub
um again this command works exactly the
same as as it does on git I'm going to
say push origin and then the name of the
branch I want to push to
hopefully this works this is the live
demo portion
very slow upload in the Microsoft
building but I did go through
so now if I refresh the page I can see
that there's the stack new Slash new
cities branch and if I load that Branch
now I'm looking at the file as it exists
or sorry the table as it exists on that
Branch but I want to go and merge that
thing back into the main branch I can
open a pull request to do so
so my base branch is going to be uh so
I'm going to merge into main from Zach
new cities
your description
create the pull request
uh so now I've got this this pull
request sitting and pending and it's
exactly the same workflow a little bit
stripped down that you would see on
GitHub in order to do a code review now
let's say data review so I can look at
the diff I can see exactly what's
changed what changes are being proposed
to emerge from The Source Branch into my
into my main branch uh I can I can pass
this off to a colleague and say hey
double check me on this make sure
everything works the way that I think it
should they can leave comments we can go
back and forth and I can make additional
changes but you get the idea
uh so one thing that we think is really
cool that we've built using this
workflow workflow that I just demoed is
our bounties program so we had this idea
we wanted to crowdsource open data sets
so we wanted to kind of put out the call
on social media and say hey we want
everybody who's interested in this
particular area to help us scrape public
data and compose it into a into a single
unified data set for other people to use
and consume so we've done this for about
a year and a half now and we've done
about 15 of these of these bounties and
the idea is that we we pay them out
based proportionately on how much people
contribute uh so the way this works is
uh everyone who wants to participate
goes and makes a fork of the particular
database that the Bounty is hosted on on
Dual Hub and then they clone that fork
to their uh to their level of device and
then start making what their edits using
whatever tools they want importing CSV
files uh making issuing SQL updates
connecting SQL workbenches to the tool
whatever they want to do when they've
made all their changes they upload that
back to dual hub using the push command
uh and then open a pull request and then
we actually employ a full-time employee
whose job it is to just be the referee
and administer these bounties to the
side of these pull requests which ones
are good enough quality to make it into
the final data sets uh and then at the
end of the day we have this list like
the one you see on the left this is the
scoreboard where we can because we have
a commit graph and a commit history we
can identify very accurately how much of
the data set is attributed to each
individual who participated in the
Bounty so we pay we pay out ten thousand
dollars for this particular Bounty
overall and we divide it up based on how
many lines of the final data sets they
contributed like I said we've done about
15 of these so far uh it's been going
really well and we've got some really
cool data sets that we've produced like
the graph on the right which shows kind
of the long tail of what you might
expect to pay for a C-section uh in
America
uh so if you want to learn more about
build Hub check out our GitHub
repository first and foremost it's build
Hub slash adults download the tool it's
free and open source get started using
it uh give us a star we always like when
people do that if you want to kind of
follow our development progress you can
go check out our blog on dildhall.com
blog and also play around and see what
other open data sources people have
uploaded to Delta uh that's all I've got
for I open up questions
[Music]
hey it's any questions I'm gonna pass
you the money
uh thank you so much for the talk and I
I'm fascinated by your approach to data
Version Control I'm curious about
um uh whether it's order sensitive or
does it need to be aware of what primary
keys are because it could be the same
contents it's just the order was shifted
yep so question was uh does it work with
tables that have primary keys and ones
that they don't have keys the answer is
yes uh but you do lose some uh you lose
the ability to understand what's changed
in a given row so without a primary key
there's no such thing as a row identity
to the database changing a cell in a
particular row looks the same as if you
deleted that row and added a new one
can't tell the difference because it
doesn't have row identity but it does
the diff operations do work it's just
everything looks like an ad delete as
opposed to a modification so if so if
you do Define there is a way of defining
primary keys and that can be smarter is
what you're saying right so if you so if
you have primary Keys then the the diffs
are richer because we know that this
particular Row the the following cells
change here here are the old values here
are their new values whereas if you
don't have a primary key you can't tell
others between that operation and a ad
delete oh
yeah
yeah thank you so much on is there any
equivalent of like git ignore and uh
pray commit hug for this
uh question was is there git ignore
equivalents there isn't yet this is on
our future roadmap but we haven't
implemented yet
if you want to tell us what you're doing
and why it's important come hang out
with us on our Discord Channel and talk
to us and we'll we can get a schedule
okay uh thank you so much and I like I
assumed like just disable like upgrade
hug right we don't have pre-commit hooks
we do have uh what we call Web hooks on
adult hubs after you push it'll it'll
run some arbitrary web hook to use setup
with HTTP uh but it's not the same as a
pre-commitive like you're asking that
would be another future request okay uh
thank you so much
um so I'm really fascinated by uh
you're building up this tool and having
it mirror GitHub in the problem space
obviously you know uh it's a super
interesting problem to solve and you've
committed a lot of time to solving it so
I'm wondering
um what specific problem did you
encounter that was so compelling that
made you want to build all this
infrastructure like what's your villain
origin story for doing adults okay this
is an interesting question but I'll try
to keep it brief uh so the company was
was founded by some ex-snap employees
that I happen to work with back at
Amazon the lured me into this this whole
thing and we founded the company the
idea was not to be a remote control
database it was just to be data Version
Control uh the observation was there's a
lot of data changing hands on Internet
it's a growing amount every year some
people estimate that this is like a 50
billion dollar uh business currently but
the way that they're doing this is
they're literally emailing spreadsheets
back and forth uh so they're like well
we decided we wanted to to kind of
figure out if we could bootstrap some
sort of real data sharing Hub on the
internet and that's what that's how it
gets started uh the SQL aspect of it in
the database aspect of It kind of came
over time and that's kind of the niche
and the product Market that we found
most of the people who are who are
actually paying us money to use the
product are using it to build database
applications they're not using the data
sharing use case the data sharing stuff
I think is is really cool and it sells
the park well people get excited about
it but for us it's uh that we think
people that will catch on people will be
using adult Hub to share and collaborate
on open data but it's just it's just
taking longer that
uh I think
yeah it's taking a long time to catch on
longer than we would like I was there
I got a question back here
hi thanks for the talk
um I was wondering is there a way to uh
sync your commits to dot Hub with your
get commits because it's not just the
data that changes your training
pipelines could change as well so when
you check out okay secular commit and
get you'd want to make sure that you
have like data for that pipeline yep
there there is a way We've Ended a tool
that does this but we have it hasn't
seen like rapid adoption I would say so
we it's it's not super well documented
uh but the way you implement it in git
is with they call this a smudge and a
filter I think they they call it the
terminology is strange but basically you
you give you give get a little pointer
into this other data source this is how
git lfs works so that when you run uh
get get pull you're not only pulling the
local data but your your it's it's using
that hook to pull down data from some
other source in the case of Git lfs it
fold it down from S3 uh in in the hook
that we implemented it pulls down that
data set locally from adult hover mode
so there is a way to do this it's a
little bit cumbersome or looking for
better techniques to actually make it
work better
okay one more back here
any interest or plans in supporting
nosql databases
so
if you squint adult it is a nosql
database you just don't run the database
server right like this is kind of how
how pandas and data frames and other
things work is you just you take the
entire database and load it into memory
and run whatever Transformations you
want and people are using uh adult that
way but our in terms of the database
features that were that we're developing
we're definitely on the on the side of
SQL we just that's that's kind of the
direction we've chosen
uh are are people using it for analytics
I guess the storage format appears very
row based and which seems kind of
integral to the actual product itself
because if you're using primary keys to
diff then there's fast single you know
single searches are important so I'm
just kind of wondering it's kind of
related to his question but like I'm
just wondering if people are doing that
right so so people are using it for
analytics I think the ltp use case is
the more common one uh but it does run
large queries it's not optimized for
them because like it is Rob Base it's
not a column or store the way they can
find a lot of other data warehouse
products it does work for that it's just
the performance is not going to be there
so we've got the kind of the correctness
in terms of being able to run large
analog queries but uh in terms of being
able to compete with something like
snowflake which is a columnar store
we're not there yet
um at some point we may offer a columnar
version of the product in order to
specifically address this use case
are there any special uh schema design
considerations when you have merge
ability of your database
there are one thing that we ran into
really early is that people in the MySQL
world really like this Auto incremental
functioning uh in postgres they call
them sequences but it's a way to get an
automatic monotonically increasing ID in
a particular table when you do this with
with different tables it becomes kind of
a disaster because my branch and your
branch have a different idea of what
what row one is so we've we've kind of
uh we do support this the way we
supported it was making this this Auto
increment counter go up globally across
all branches when you're running the
server as opposed to individually for
each branch to avoid the merge conflicts
but it's still not a great idea most the
time what you want is if you and I have
a have a copy of the database and we
both make the same set of insert
statements we should end up with the
same database it should be identical
down to the down to the hash and there's
there's things you can do with like
generating the values of columns that
violate that that assumption and the
tool still works it just you lose some
of the some of the cool use cases that
you could do you get merge conflict
where you wouldn't have wanted them
another question right here
someone related
um
how much of like the primary key set up
something like the schema idiosyncrasies
to get this to work how much of that is
sort of like
built in and abstracted from the user
it's like how aware do you have to be of
some of these things in order to get
adult to actually function properly so
if you're doing the kind of a data
import case you have to be aware enough
about the about the structure of your
data in order to tell adults what the
primary key is that's kind of that's
kind of the table stakes and you have to
know a little bit of SQL because we have
tools that try to infer the schema based
on a CSV file and stuff but they're not
perfect uh for example they'll choose
like the wrong size for a for a bar
chart column and so on uh so you do need
to be able to to know how to run a table
statement and SQL but beyond that
everything kind of just works the way
that you should you've done a lot of
work in getting uh compatibility to work
with basically every MySQL tool and
Library Under the Sun so these days it's
it's surprising if somebody
spins up some random MySQL library to
connect to the database and it doesn't
work most of the time
you may have actually just answered my
question but I was just kind of come
back to the analytics use case is there
um you're following my sequels dialect
is anything you had to add on top of
that to kind of handle things like maybe
joining against the same data set but at
a different snapshot in time or
something or is that yeah that's
supported within the existing dialect
right so it's it's it didn't require any
extensions to the dialect per se uh I
I'll generalize your question and say
how do you access the kind of Version
Control capabilities within within a SQL
context right so instead of checking out
a branch on the command line and then
querying that Branch you can actually do
that within a SQL session so there's the
SQL extension that was added in like
2011 uh where you can use the as of
keyword in a query so adult we implement
this uh if you say select star from my
table as of and then give it the name of
a branch uh now you're looking at adapts
you're looking at the data from that
Branch for that query you can access all
the functionality from the command line
through a combination of system tables
and stored procedures to do things like
make commits push them to remotes uh
diff two commits those are all available
in this equal context but it's a lot of
stuff to demo so I didn't really have
time to squeeze it all in there
we have one more question
yeah so I was just trying to understand
you so each table is like corresponds to
a file is that like a good
is that correct that's generally
speaking CSV files kind of map each of
them to a table it's difficult to
be because they have one schema
throughout throughout right so that's
typically how people map their data
um
so
yep all the all the branching
capabilities apply to all the tables and
the database every branch and in fact
you can have branches where some
branches contain a particular table or
have a different schemail on a
particular table than other branches and
that's all fine it works away
right if if you're coming from a data
analysis world where you're used to
feeding some CSV files into pandas and
shooting up some results uh the right
mental model is that each of those files
is now a table